-How are you, Neil?
-Hey. Hey. I'm doing great
Well, sorry.
The universe is great.
It's Earth that's messed up.
-Alright.
Thank you for making
the clarification.
Now, we are coming up
on an election,
and it just feels like
anything might happen.
And now I'm hearing tell tha
there might be an asteroid
heading towards Earth
on Election Day.
True or false, Neil?
-It's true. It's true.
It's about -- It's a
refrigerator-sized asteroid.
And given the uncertainty
in this orbit,
there's a small sliver of
that uncertainty
that includes colliding
with Earth on November 2nd
-And what would be the fallout
of a refrigerator-sized
meteor hitting us?
-Yeah, I mean, you would see i
if you were anywhere in
sight line of when it hit.
It's going, you know,
10 or 20 miles per second.
When you hit air,
even though air feels like
you can just move through it
if you're going really fast,
it's like you are hitting
a brick wall.
So it would explode on impact.
You would see it all around.
There would be
a tremendous meteor shower
But, no, it's not going to
harm anyone, no.
But just the idea.
It's like, you know,
the universe is saying,
"Here, take that."
-The first I've heard in month
that's not going to harm anyone.
-Yes.
-This must be
a very strange time to be
a scientist
and to see how people,
particularly American people
are reacting to data.
Is it as frustrating
as I imagine it is
as you watch
the response to COVID?
That's a "yes."
It looks like the clenched fists
are a classic "yes" from Neil.
-Yeah, that's my miming
of how it feels.
You know, I keep wondering
"What am I doing?"
And all these others
who are on this landscape
of science education --
they have YouTube channels
and books and video.
And then I have to tell myself
"Maybe, without all of this,
it would be much worse."
See, that's why -- Otherwise
nothing is working, right?
So I don't know how else
to feel good about any of this
But, yeah, it's frustrating.
And we went into that with the
whole flat-Earth people.
You know, I don't understand
I think science
needs to be taught
not as a satchel of facts,
but as a way of understandin
what is objectively true
in nature.
And then, you know,
as evidence comes and goes
"Okay, they're good.
That's good evidence.
Oh, no, no."
And then you can sort of
ride the surf into the futur
of our understanding
of how the universe works.
And that's
the only way to assure
that civilization will
survive ourselves.
-Well, that speaks to the fact
that this is fluid.
Obviously, we're learning more
about this pandemic every day,
and it's very unfair
to ask people, on day one,
to know all the answers
we have on day 200.
You have described it as sort of
akin to an alien invasion.
Can you explain that analogy
-Yeah, sure.
I mean, think about it.
Suppose aliens came,
and they were just going to be
the enemies
of all humans, right?
We'd band together, wouldn't we?
We would say,
"Let's put down our differences,
because we have a common enemy
that we must defeat."
Well, the coronavirus, COVID
is exactly that, right?
It doesn't care
what your skin color is,
what country you're born in,
who you worship,
who you sleep with.
It doesn't distinguish.
It doesn't care.
And all the things that
tribally divide us,
it only cares if you're human.
And so this is a test.
It's a test.
How do we, as a species,
react to a common threat?
And I rate us a C-minus in
how we have collectively
reacted to this.
To have one state open up
its restrictions
while another state
doesn't that's adjacent to it?
And I think to myself,
that's like designating
a peeing section
of a swimming pool.
That's exactly what that's like,
so I don't know what to say.
-Well, I think you've said i
pretty well right there.
You -- This season of "Cosmos"
is about possible worlds.
This is sort of other worlds
that might exist,
which I think probably sound
pretty attractive to people.
Tell us a little bit about it.
-Yeah, yeah. Thanks for asking
I mean, possible worlds --
the obvious interpretation is,
there are exoplanets that we
might visit or populate
just to escape Earth.
But I think,
more on a deeper level,
a possible world is -- think o
the possible futures of Eart
that we have control over.
Each of those different path
is a different world.
So "possible worlds"
is very broadly interprete
in terms of how we can
harness the power,
the awesome power,
of the methods and tools o
science and technology and
engineering to shape a futur
that -- where we will not only
survive, but thrive.
And it's a future of Earth
where our descendants
will be proud for what
we have done,
rather than embarrassed fo
what we didn't do
or for the wanton neglect
that we have expressed
on trying to sustain
our relationship
with the ecosystem
that has sustained us.
-Well, thank you for alway
being a voice for science.
I know, at times,
it sounds like or seems like
no one's listening, but I assure
you a lot of people are.
And it's always a pleasure
to see you, Neil.
Thanks for making time for us.
-Well, thank you.
And "Cosmos" is all about hope
You know, every episode,
we could say,
"You're all going to die,"
but we pose the problem
and we give a thread of hope
and that's what
we all need right now.
-I am a little worried tha
next season
is going to be "Cosmos: We'r
All Going to Die."
But the third season,
the optimistic season,
of "Cosmos"
premieres Tuesday on Fox.